Bowling world,
it's Saroj and today we're going to do
some GPU programming to add the elements
of two arrays together.
Sound super simple, I know,
but it will be a way for us to introduce
ourselves to the key concepts that make
up the incredible world of parallel
computing used heavily in deep learning.
The field of computer graphics traces
its roots back to the earliest days of
computer science,
HP and IBM or some of the first companies
to introduce silicon hardware capable
of generating imagery which helped fuel
the decades long transformation of the
southern SF bay area into the
technology hub known as Silicon Valley.
There were endless applications of
computer graphics in everything from
scientific simulations
to movies to video games.
Programmers created graphical software
and that software was broken down into a
series of instructions that the central
processing unit of a computer was
capable of carrying out.
The CPU is the main chip in a computer
responsible for telling all the other
components in a computer what to do using
it's given instructions just like your
friendly neighborhood dictator.
If we look at the difference between
your early games and modern day games,
it is truly remarkable how much of
a difference in realism there is.
The process of rendering a seen consists
of a number of steps a computer must
perform in a specific sequence and the
sequence is called the graphics pipeline.
The first step is to set up
the objects in the scene.
Object models are a mesh of
triangles that describe its shape.
This is done by listing the
exact coordinates of every
corner of every triangle.
Coordinate systems need an
origin and in a model's file,
it's just an arbitrary place, but
the place, the model in the scene,
all the vertex coordinates need to be
transformed so that the origin is now a
place in the scene.
Once the objects are placed in the scene,
the coordinates are again
transformed into camera space.
These transformations require the use
of matrix operations for older games.
With simple models.
This was entirely doable by a CPU,
but as models got more complex,
the amount of transformations outgrew
the capabilities of a CPU alone.
So a company named and video
came along and released.
The first graphics processing unit in
99 capable of hardware transform and
lighting a CPU consists of a few
cores optimize for sequential serial
processing.
While a GPU has a massively parallel
architecture consisting of thousands of
smaller,
more efficient course designed for
handling multiple tasks simultaneously.
So while traditionally software has been
written for serial computation where
instructions are executed
one after the other,
there are some algorithms that can be
framed to utilize parallel computation.
Searching for a specific
word in a document, for
example, can be done serially.
That means iterating through
every word from start to finish,
but it can also be done in parallel by
having 10 different workers search a
different section of the document
for our target word at the same time.
But some algorithms like calculating
the Nth FIBONACCI number can't be made
parallel since we can only find it after
the proceeding to Fibonacci numbers
have been calculated in order.
Matrix operations for deep learning
can easily be parallelized.
Deep neural networks can have
millions of parameters to train,
all of which can be done much
faster by utilizing GPU. Yes,
there are several programming frameworks
out there that led programmers harness
GPU course like open cl opiod ACC,
but the most popular is Nvidia's Kuda,
which stands for compute
unified device architecture.
Kuda is a toolkit that acts
as an extension of c with
its own programming model
that lets programmers run
their code on and videos gps.
The Cu Dnn library built on top of Kuta
specifically for deep learning is used
by every single major framework from
tensorflow two Pi Torch under the hood.
So let's talk about Gpu architecture
in the way that could have used it.
The key part of Kuta code
is the kernel program.
The kernel is a function that can
be executed in parallel on the GPU.
It's executed by an array of Kuta threats.
All threads run the same code and each
thread has an id that it uses to compute
memory addresses and
make control decisions.
You can run thousands of these threads
on the GPU and Kuda organizes threads
into a grid hierarchy of thread blocks.
A grid is a set of thread blocks
that can be processed on the device.
In parallel.
Each thread block is a set of concurrent
threads that can cooperate amongst
themselves and access a shared
memory space private to the block.
It's the programmer's job to specify the
grid glock organization on each kernel
call since it can be different each time
within the limits set by their specific
GPU. Let's write some Kuta code to get
a better understanding of how all these
components play together.
We'll start with some basic c plus plus.
Our program will simply add the elements
of two arrays with a million elements,
each only two dependencies io stream,
which will help us take input commands
and show output results and math,
which defines various math operations
we can use in the main function.
We'll initialize an integer array with
space to store a million elements.
Then we'll initialize pointers
to both of our arrays, x and Y,
which space allocated for both of them
using our previously initialized variable
and we can fill both arrays by creating
a for loop and filling each index and
each array with float values.
We'll use both filled arrays
and the number of elements
in each as parameters to
an add function.
In our ad function.
We'll create a for loop to add all end
elements in each array and set the result
to each index in the y. Ira.
After this loop is finished,
why contain the sum of each elements
in both arrays? When we're done,
we can free the memory from both a res
and exit the program by returning zero.
We can save the code in this file as
ad dot CPP and compile it with a c plus
plus compiler claim for me since I'm on
Mac g plus plus if you're on windows or
Linux,
that was a simple c plus plus program.
No Kuta needed but adding the elements
in both arrays can be parallelized on
many cores of the GPU,
so let's get turnt.
The first step for us is a Turner had
function into a function that the GPU can
run called a colonel in Kuda.
All we have to do is at the global
specifier to the function and that'll tell
the Kuda c plus plus compiler that this
is a function that runs on the Gpu and
can be called from CPU code.
We also need to allocate memory that is
accessible by not just the CPU but the
GPU as well.
Karuna uses the concept of
unified memory to make this easy.
It provides a single memory space
accessible by all gps ncps on your system.
We'll need to replace the calls to new
in our code with calls to Kuta Malaak
managed.
This will allocate data in unified
memory and returns a pointer that we can
access from CPU or Gpu code.
After this,
we can launch the ad colonel on the Gpu
by using the triple angle bracket syntax.
We'll just add it to the call
to add before the parameter
list and the CPU needs
to wait until the kernel is done
before it accesses the results.
Because Kuda colonel launches
don't block the calling CPU thread.
We can make this happen by
calling Kuda device synchronize.
Before freeing the memory are one liner
launched one GPU thread to run ad.
We can save this code in a file called
ad.cu for Cuda and compile it with NBCC,
the Kuda c plus plus compiler as written.
The kernel is only correct for a single
thread. Since every thread that it runs,
we'll perform add on the whole array.
We can find out how long it
takes to colonel to run by
using the GPU profiler as
well,
but can we make it faster?
Our execution configuration tells the
cooter runtime how many parallel threads
to use for the launch on the GPU.
There are two parameters here.
Let's change the second one,
which is the number of threads
in a thread block Kuda gps,
Ron kernels using blocks of threads
that are a multiple of 32 in size,
so let's try to 56 but doing this alone
will cause it to do the computation once
per thread rather than spreading the
computation across parallel threads.
To do it properly,
we need to modify the kernel.
We can get the indices of the running
threads using the thread id keyword for
the current thread and it's
block and the block dim keyword.
For the number of threads in the block,
we can modify the loop to stride
through the array with parallel threats.
If we save it and run it again,
we'll see a huge speedup.
It went from using one thread to
two 56 threads, so this makes sense.
To summarize what we've learned.
Kuda is a toolkit that lets programmers
use Nvidia's Gpu to parallelize their
code.
It's an extension of see with its own
programming model consisting of threads,
blocks and grids and the newer version
uses a unified memory architecture which
lets us access allocated
data from CPU and Gpu Code.
Winter of last week's coding
challenges out there too.
He used to neural network based models
that he implemented in tensorflow.
We popular indicators from the field of
market analysis to predict trends give
his costar star on get hub
and the runner up is who top,
who converted to stock prices into audio
data and ran deep minds wavenet on it.
What a while and brilliant idea.
I love it.
This week's challenge is to add Kuda to
a simple algorithm and benchmark just
how fast the speedup was.
Details are in the read me poster,
get hope link in the comments and
winners will be announced next week.
I hope you liked this video.
Please subscribe if you did,
and for now I've got to free up
some memory, so thanks for watching.